we have a voicemail number it is two one
nine two david p i want to get to
something that was asked for many times
late in 2017 take a listen to this hey
david cold me in austin again uh i was
wondering you can you gives like the
origin story of the eggman like i've
listened to your show daily for like a
year and a half or something i have no
idea who this guy is but you seem to
really like him so how did he become a
david pakman show voicemail regular
that's my question yeah so basically the
eggman is a guy who lives in rural
upstate new york he is someone who is a
jewish individual who has also served
time and i believe it was a federal
penitentiary for some kind of
drug-related charge he was a victim of
the war on drugs i didn't get as fair to
say he is a pitbull rescue advocate he
is in favor of the death penalty and he
is against hate crime legislation i
think that those are a few sort of data
points about the eggman
i don't know why he goes by the eggman
and i don't know if that relates to the
Sonic the Hedgehog game or if it relates
to the Beatles Beatles song I am The
Walrus yeah that's something with that I
don't know but in any case his real name
I'm not actually gonna say what his real
name is but it's funny because we know
him as the Eggman of a drug prison Fame
but his real name is something like very
stereotypically Jewish sounding like
it's not this but it's like if I said Oh
his real name is Jonathan Rosenbaum
that's not actually the egg man's name
but just imagine that that is something
like that and he just started calling in
years ago I don't really know he calls
in and he has this familiar sign-off
where he says Shalom I don't know what
he looks like
do a 5 I'll show you are you if you
check his out his Twitter I think he has
posted pictures there before it is not
what you would imagine like from his
voice what do you think he looks like um
like a middle-aged guy rugged okay I
sense strong guy oh it actually thank
very confident he's definitely more from
the pictures I've seen he's definitely
more of like a big bearded right I
imagine a beard oh okay so you I I
imagine something completely different
when I first heard about the egg man but
in any case that's
the backstory on the Eggman and that's
really most of what I know I'm not sure
even if the Eggman is a member if he is
it might be oh no I think he watches the
bonus show he does watch the bonus one
way or another somehow he's getting
access to it yeah all right so anyway
those are the origins for the Eggman it
might be interesting to do origin
stories for the different people that
call in like for example the Kansas
troll who have not actually heard from
for a long time
Troy York Troy York who has called in
under probably six different names he
has personas of all different races
there's like a Hispanic character that
he calls in with I forget the guys name
it's something like is it like Luis
Rodriguez I don't remember now yeah and
then he has like a stereotypical black
guy name I don't remember what that one
is in any way I we'd have to do a list
of all those regular callers what would
there be would be like a whole
miniseries wouldn't it could be a
miniseries the next one when we get to
7,000 patrons will do an origin story
miniseries on all regular colors all
right the bonus show today is just about
Bombo Genesis snowpocalypse and we'll be
defining all those terms really really
precisely for you if I showed you what's
going on outside our studio window right
now you would be shocked or maybe not if
you've been watching the news but it is
basically complete whiteout conditions
Pat's wearing gigantic snow boots I'm
even wearing snow boots let's see if I
can show them to you here ooh and I
never wear snow boots I'm holding my
boots over the desk right now I call
this the David Pakman show
the David Pakman show yeah that's that's
exactly and I have such terrible boots
that little things like this thing is
just I just ripped off the label that
says weatherproof trash these are the
were these are like $30 boots that I've
had for maybe eight years or something
but anyway we'll talk about that on the
bonus show today